running some holiday cheer this year
positively arts a non-profit group that
provides
free performing arts training for kids
is finding virtual ways to warm your
heart this winter
bianca holman has our story i want a
hippopotamus for christmas
eleven-year-old
riley cole is a triple threat dance
acting
and singing she loves it all when i went
into the studio
i was very very very very very excited
to go and record a song
rylan is a member of positively arts a
las vegas non-profit
offering performing arts training for
kids regardless of their ability to pay
the pandemic has forced the group to
make changes
to ensure these talented children and
teens continue to live out their passion
ryland's mother says her daughter has
blossomed since her first performance
we were just very impressed that her
confidence and her ability to move
around and
it was incredible we know that when a
student is involved in the arts
it not only helps them develop
confidence but it also builds their
critical and creative thinking skills
palita simpson the group's founder says
the annual winter fundraisers have gone
virtual
the kids recorded a holiday album
featuring broadway
artists and grammy nominated producers
they've got singing grams for donors and
a home for the holidays spectacular
that will be streamed online while
simpson and the young performers miss
the stage
there's a bright spot to posting on the
web it's been really
awesome putting kids online because
we're able to actually reach more people
the donations go straight to the
students
paying for lessons that last a lifetime
they are
zooming with us they are scrapping with
us they're doing whatever they can
just to help us they're getting
opportunities that they couldn't find
anywhere else there's no
barriers there it's it's programs for
kids regardless of their background
reporting bianca holman 8 news now the
holiday show will air on december 15th
the the time rather on the positively
artists website that's where you can
find it
the group hopes to raise ten thousand
dollars to pay for student singing
acting
and dance classes for those who can't
afford it